I got a flashbac I ever did that host
club here I got an email from a
prostitution website and a bad did you
actually they were like and they'd sent
me videos of like on lively of people
filming hahaha the cover they were like
this is what you can do if you want
sound legal I was on the train and
awesome yeah I'll open this link for
some reason I open this link it's a
Raging Blast but yeah they were like if
you want we'll arrange escorts for you
and you can film the whole thing and I'm
like from what from which process of
this oh I need to like get approval from
brasses to use their logo is that
something that I need that's not
strength I should find me I'll find the
email if we had take a break or whatever
but like it was they were they were
basically like saying if you want to
order any prostitutes to make a video
about it in Japan yeah I can totally
like I don't know why I can totally see
you doing a video or it's like I tried
escorts in Japan with my prostitute
that's like PQ super clickbait here
right I tried to be an escort gone wrong
no Gong sex you helped me on the website
yeah and I looked at it and it was like
it was legit that was like videos of
like like someone had like a secret
GoPro yeah something and they were
filming it and it was really doesn't
sound cool it was very disturbed yeah
and I quickly turned it off and when
they started talking about what acts
they were gonna perform for what price
and I just found it so odd that they
watched my host club video and that they
were like this seems like a natural
evolution
I would like to hire an escort CD [ __ ]
given your recipe short time in Japan
the government please leave me alone
yeah I did worry if like the host club
would like raise any like suspicions or
anything but I was like [ __ ] it I think
it's a really interesting concept if I
hand go well it should be fine yeah yeah
that was that took forever to come ahead
it but they are enough about that anyway
yeah I mean like you know she has gone
real when you see the liveleak logo like
I had what I didn't even see it wasn't
on lively it was Ali it was
link to a video with a lively clerk oh
okay Oh No